we
saw
this entire engagement that we're about
to go over on uh twitter and i just love
this i i i don't even know uh what
people are gonna react to this but when
i saw this i was like man that's the
energy we needed 2022. so kobe on
twitter basically tweeted and said the
outrage from gamers over the inclusion
of nfts is an astronomical unwitting
vote against self-interest if gaming
companies are able to build more
sustainable revenue models without
paywall dlc nfts can improve player
experience even if you opt out of buying
them yourself basically saying listen
this is supposed to be pro gamer this
should be accepted and welcomed by the
community even if you yourself don't
want to participate don't ruin the fun
for other people they actually can
benefit greatly from this so of course
then came the reply crowd the peanut
gallery jumping in and everything from
when the question becomes do you want to
truly own your items have them become
sellable or interoperable you can't
really argue with it it's just noobs
that hear crypto and nft and are turned
off and think it's a money grab and it's
intruding on their experience and here
they come i play clean games a lot i
have zero interest in owning any of my
in-game items that's okay for one person
to say that but of course what if other
people want to do it you shouldn't
change what they want to do right well
crypto ohio i think is how you pronounce
that if you got a one out of 100 skin
and you could post it in on any in-game
marketplace for say 50 that wouldn't
interest you you'd rather that the
company control that locked economy
weird play a lot of games too and i
would love that you should get the
option to participate though to be fair
and it continues on and on and on and on
but the next important one was somebody
jumps in and says why make it a one of
100 doesn't make it cool like we get it
you're a crypto pro and you've never
heard about cs go we get it now f off
now of course
this is where kobe had to make a
decision could go down one path and say
no f off u and get super abrasive or
be an absolute
king
do exactly what he did
interesting to resort to hostility name
calling so quickly why bother to tweet
at all l-o-l
person responded 99 of the internet is
tired of your breed of people that's
pretty crazy shoving crypto and nft down
people's throats trying to run the next
pyramid
scheme hell's square's statement was met
with pure f off just like you should so
kobe put on his crown and he simply
responded with i'll give you ten
thousand dollars if you make an ethereum
address and buy a single nft i'll cover
the cost of the nft let me know if
you're interested which is one of those
mic drop boss moves on the internet that
should be in the twitter hall of fame
this person responded and said i would
be stupid to say no to such an offer
because it's basically free money for me
even if i despise them i'd be a bigger
fool to turn down free money but why
would you give a stranger 10 grand much
less no i'm not being double fooled
kobe said i guess i am literally shoving
crypto and nfts down your throat like
you previously accused me open wide and
give me your etherium actress
which only further propagated this into
the twitter hall of fame of all
interactions of course this person
followed up with their ethereum address
just as kobe demanded and said i guess
and i would like to apologize in saying
the wording perhaps was a bit wrong more
we have to constantly hear about it left
and right and how it'll improve x y z
now the back pedaling that's occurring
as you send your ethereum address to
somebody who's about to give you ten
thousand dollars is all time that just
came out real quick you're not just back
pedaling you're basically on
rollerblades just wheeling backwards at
a very high rate of speed
kobe been a man of his word said sent
you a thousand dollars to buy an nft
suggest using open c and finding
something from a small artist i like
this uh league cryptograph stuff but you
can choose or ask for help when you've
bought your first nft i'll send you the
ten thousand dollars welcome to crypto
you big eco terrorist
if now i got him on the hook and now
they're gonna be an nft holder of course
he's gonna now press the gas he's gonna
attack further not 10 grand you're a lot
of crack jokes oh you're allowed to call
somebody an eco-terrorist for sure and
so this person said image proof of
purchase and same wallet you can look up
on openc as said before i'm not with
this but you have gained the respect of
at least me then kobe sent ten thousand
dollars and also sent you the ens availa
dot eth so you could set your eth
address to use your twitter name instead
of the garbled ox
whatever stuff if you'd like to remain
intellectually curious and crypto spend
it all on an xbox if you want but be
careful don't kill a rain forest now
this is very interesting because
obviously
that whether you're into bitcoin whether
you're into ethereum nfts social tokens
whatever whatever you're into into this
entire ecosystem we can't simply go and
offer person by person around the world
for seven plus billion people ten
thousand dollars to go ahead and get
adopted but what ends up being really
interesting about this is that
ultimately an economic incentive over
what overwhelms somebody how do you say
no when you get this offer you can't and
so ultimately i think that what we're
starting to see is that there are
companies as they have done in web 2 and
other areas that say you know what i'm
going to pay you to adopt my actual
platform i'll give you 10 if you go
ahead and you sign up we've seen
companies like paypal do this for
decades literally pay 10 or if you sign
up your friend you get 10 and your
friend gets 10 that has been a way to
acquire users for a very long time now
what we are seeing here though is it's
not just companies doing this was a
ability for a peer-to-peer kind of user
acquisition if you will and so
ultimately i think that we're seeing
this happen more and more sometimes it's
not just i'll give you 10 000 obviously
sometimes it's hey i'll send you
something whether it's literally i'll
send you a dollar of bitcoin i'll send
you an nft that's really cheap it
doesn't almost matter what the economic
value of the item is but simply being
able to onboard your friends and your
family being able to say i will send you
something i'll welcome you into this new
world by giving you some sort of
incentive to log in and of course
when it comes to something like bitcoin
if you went around and you told all of
your friends hey i'll give you five
dollars a bitcoin just download a wall
and i'll send it to you obviously you
would get a number of your friends and
family to go ahead and actually get the
wallet and to hold bitcoin once they
start to hold it they start to pay
attention once they start to pay
attention they get educated and once
they get educated they begin to adopt it
more and more but with all that said
that's all the warm and fuzzy stuff i
think that we just got to tip our cap to
kobe and just say
respect sir that was a fantastic hall of
fame thread joe what did you think would
you say that was all time i was dying
laughing when he said
give me your wallet address and open
wide i was like jeez dude um but yeah it
was it was really funny obviously the uh
the participant is gonna gonna partake
in that they're like hey you're gonna
send me ten thousand dollars for free
essentially uh if i go set up a wall and
buy an nft no brainer for them but it's
just funny i think it's more so a joke
you're not gonna be able to send ten
thousand dollars to your point to
everyone to get them to download the
customer acquisition cost would be uh
out of this world for some of these
things but ultimately i think kobe was
just having some fun and i got a good
laugh out of it too
john yeah i mean that was a goaded
threat as they say literally hilarious
at the end of it he literally gave
someone 10 000
so we've seen company or countries even
el salvador was giving away thirty
dollars um to be able to onboard people
onto their chivo app right every tech
company has done this for a very very
long time it's paying people because
incentives drive the world and if you
want to get someone interested it's also
cool to see look if you had zero dollars
in any cryptocurrency and then someone
gave you 10 000 in that cryptocurrency
you're gonna start paying attention to
the market in some sense right so it's
basically an educational payment um that
that person received because i doubt
that person just sells that ten thousand
dollars right away it's more hey look
let me go learn about this and can teach
you a lot about other asset classes as
well so it's pretty cool to see hats off
to kobe for even doing this um and yeah
how much would you spend to onboard
somebody who was talking [ __ ] to you
talking [ __ ] like would you be like a
hundred dollars my language i know
there's kids that watch this a hundred
dollars uh i'm not trying to fuel people
that come to my twitter
and talk crap to me yeah i'm not giving
anyone yeah no no no no
no no would you have i haven't given
crypto two friends how much how much i
gave anywhere from fifty to a hundred
dollars i'm not no
boss
but i gave it there
are we friends or what damn you they
sent me 50 of bitcoin
i gave it to them because i thought that
would be enough monetary value to where
they would actually take interest in it
if i sent someone two dollars of it i
don't think they would really care about
it but i think 50 and 100 is just like
hey look like as long as you have
everything set up like here's 50 bucks
and uh i hope that it grows to more
right the first person selling that the
the first time yeah pro you're probably
selling the crypto uh i i think it was
yeah
i don't know what was sent but yeah uh
whatever uh kobe center i'm sure they're
gonna sell that for the ten thousand
dollars so they probably don't believe
but the nft i'm assuming that that is
hold yeah right um when uh you think
they just they get the 10 000 and just
run off with the bag and just sell it
probably probably yeah i mean if you're
not a believer then like the economic
incentive would be to sell you just got
ten thousand dollars go buy yourself a
car or something right yeah and it
depends on their personal situation if
they really really need ten thousand
dollars and that wipes away all their
debt or something like that
i wouldn't sell that if somebody on the
internet gives you ten thousand dollars
for free and you buy a car are you
automatically obligated to make their
twitter handle the license plate
like i said is there somebody riding
around with a brand new car they gotta
put kobe as license plate like there's a
high probability that that's what you
have respect you gotta do yeah like if
you buy a house you gotta change the
street literally to like i live at 101
kobe drive right or like like there's
all kinds of things he's getting you at
least get a bumper stick yeah
if some stranger on the internet gives
you money when they were talking [ __ ] to
you and they give you a bunch of money
you go buy something you got to somehow
give them credit for it whether it's a
license plate or or something else
there's got to be something that you do
there right
yeah for sure okay yeah john's thinking
right now like what would i do yeah
you got to give them some like basically
like thank you right but i think so
imagine if you gave someone 10 000 to
onboard them into um a digital asset and
they posted a picture and said thanks
for the new car
i mean i just thought it was funny
because there's there's uh the guy was
obviously talking [ __ ] and trolling and
there's no better response than just
like go create one i'll give you money
because then he has to do it and then
you can say that he was on board yeah
eco-terrorist
he's just trolling the guy really